[Aplausos]
[Música]
Esta es la pregunta del millón de
dólares puede sobrevivir la economía de
Ucrania a una invasión rusa o dicho de
otra forma como afectaría una invasión
Rusia a los ucranianos que viven en los
territorios no ocupados podrían mantener
sus empresas o se verían relegados a
subsistir me explico en estos momentos
todas las opciones están abiertas Putin
no se ha limitado a invadir el este de
Ucrania sino que ha llegado hasta la
capital es decir hasta quién Qué
significa todo esto pues lo cierto es
que no lo sabemos puede que Rusia y
Ucrania termine en una guerra abierta
que se prolongaría durante años o tal
vez terminen en un alto el fuego en
visualpolitik no tenemos una bola de
cristal pero si tenemos otra cosa mucha
memoria porque sí mis queridos amigos de
la comunidad de visualpolitik existe un
precedente muy parecido a Ucrania un
país que también ha sido invadido por
Putin De qué país estamos hablando
exacto de Georgia
[Música]
y no no me refiero al estado de Estados
Unidos sino al país Georgia con capital
en tiflis significa esto que los
ucranianos van a correr la misma suerte
que los georgianos no Pero nadie puede
negar que hay un montón de similitudes
además Georgia puede enseñar un montón
de lecciones si sois nómadas digitales o
estáis ligeramente interesados en este
estilo de vida seguramente hayáis oído
mencionar este país miles de veces
porque se trata de uno de los destinos
de moda para pequeños emprendedores y
nómadas digitales y en fin os tengo que
confesar que aquí en visualpolitik
tenemos un cariño muy especial este país
y diréis por qué Pues porque nuestro
primer vídeo viral fue un vídeo que
dedicamos a Georgia corría el año 2016
cuando todavía no teníamos ni mil
suscriptores y en fin que nos iba a
decir entonces que la comunidad de
visualpolitik va a ser tan grande que
hoy en día hasta tendríamos camisetas
Por cierto queréis haceros con nuestro
merchandising exclusivo pues no está a
la venta la única forma de conseguirlo
Es entrando en nuestro patreon vamos que
estas camisetas que exclusivas de verdad
Y por cierto Todos los diseños están
hechos por nosotros dicho de otra forma
que si entráis a formar parte del
patreon de visualpolitik no solo Vais a
ayudar a que este proyecto siga adelante
con toda la independencia y el rigor que
tanto os gusta sino que además
accederéis a merchandising realmente
exclusivo y a nuestra newsletter de
análisis político que es un auténtico
lujazo pero volvamos con nuestra
historia de hoy
Lo cierto es que Georgia es uno de los
países más interesantes del mundo
especialmente por este señor que veis en
pantalla
os presento al expresidente de Georgia
mijail sacasvini si este hombre hubiera
nacido en San Francisco os aseguro que
tendría por lo menos tres series de
Netflix y dos del hbo de hecho creo que
es el único político de la historia que
puede presumir de haber ocupado cargos
de responsabilidad política en dos
países distintos uno es Georgia y el
otro cuál diréis que es 1 2 3 Exacto
Ucrania tras gobernar Georgia sacasville
consiguió la ciudadanía ucraniana y
llegó a ser gobernador de la región de
odesa absolutamente todo en la vida de
este hombre es digno de película podrá
gustaros más o menos pero en nadie
absolutamente nadie puede negar que es
un personaje único en la historia un
señor que levanta pasiones y odios y
diréis quienes su mayor hater Exacto
Vladimir Putin y ojo porque esta vez
hablamos de odio de verdad atentos
porque esto es una declaración textual
algún día colgaré a esa Jazmín y de las
pelotas
[Música]
Bueno si Putin te dice eso ya puedes
empezar a asustarte
[Aplausos]
y diréis Pero por qué tanto odio pues lo
cierto Es que la quinta parte del
territorio de Georgia está ocupada por
Rusia y así lleva desde el año 2008
cuando estalló la guerra de Georgia
habéis oído bien podríamos decir que
Georgia es como una Ucrania en miniatura
Así que la pregunta es cómo es posible
que ella tantos nómadas digitales que se
marchan a vivir a un país invadido ha
sobrevivido Georgia a la invasión rusa
qué elecciones puede aprender Ucrania de
esta historia y qué errores ha cometido
Georgia hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
la aldea de borat
Ya lo hemos dicho si eres un nómada
digital probablemente hayas oído hablar
de Georgia o incluso estés ahí en estos
momentos viendo nuestro vídeo Georgia
sigue siendo un país pobre pero a la vez
han llegado a pedir entrar en la Unión
Europea todo esto es una historia de
Cuento de hadas si tenemos en cuenta que
hace 20 años Georgia era Cómo decirlo
habéis visto amoret pues al Georgia a la
aldea de borak parecería Manhattan este
país era la cristalización de todos los
estereotipos que tengáis en la cabeza de
una República exoviática mafias
corrupción y muchísima pobreza durante
la Guerra Fría Georgia era una República
dentro de la unión soviética pero en
1991 declararon la independencia y
entraron en guerra con Moscú al igual
que está ocurriendo en Ucrania Georgia
tiene dos provincias cuya población se
siente más rusa que georgiana en este
caso hablamos de osetia del sur y Acacia
desde 1992 son dos regiones de esas que
aparecen sombreadas con rayitas en los
mapas y diréis Y qué ha pasado en el
resto del país pues para ser honestos
nada bueno Muchos de vosotros pensaríais
que el fin del comunismo fueron buenas
noticias para todos los que vivían en la
unión soviética sin embargo Georgia es
uno de los casos donde no fue así
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en solo 10
años el pib de Georgia cayó a menos de
la mitad es más que este país sigue
sufriendo una pérdida de población
brutal en 1989 Georgia tenía cerca de 5
millones de habitantes ahora están en
3,7 millones de personas y diréis pero
como es posible que las cosas vayan tan
mal en este lugar pensadlo bien en los
años 90 Georgia se convirtió en el campo
de cultivo perfecto para mafias y
políticos corruptos pero no solo eso la
poca industria que había en el país
venía desde Moscú de la época soviética
una vez se independizaron todas las
fábricas cerraron para que os hagáis una
idea Durante los años 90 la principal
exportación georgiana era la chatarra
que habían dejado los soviéticos en las
fábricas yderúrgicas Sí sí habéis oído
bien la principal exportación de Georgia
eran los Trozos de metal que quedaban en
las fábricas que se acababan de cerrar
con esto ya os podéis imaginar cómo
estaba el país Por otra parte tampoco es
nada que os sorprenda hablamos de la
región del cáucaso todos los países y
las regiones de esta zona están igual lo
peor por esta zona es donde azerbaiyán
Armenia chechenia vamos que estamos
hablando de una de las zonas más oscuras
del planeta como diríamos en español de
España Más chungas sin embargo el
destino de Georgia cambió para siempre
en el año 2003 y diréis Pero qué ocurrió
en este momento pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
la revolución de Las Rosas
Hay momentos en la historia en los que
contra todo pronóstico una persona lo
cambia todo y este es uno de esos casos
Y sí la persona de la que estamos
hablando es mijael sacasville alguno
dirá que este vídeo es una alabanza o
una loa a la figura de este hombre pero
realmente si dejamos a un lado la
opinión que se pueda tener sobre este
señor Nadie puede negar que lo ha vivido
absolutamente todo objetivamente este
señor ha cambiado completamente la
historia de su país y os lo digo en
serio aquí en visualpolitik que hemos
analizado ya un montón de países y de
figuras políticas y aún así la vida de
sacas Billy es una película en el vídeo
de hoy Solamente vamos a contaros una
pequeña parte y es que en el año 2003
mijail sacasville era un abogado que
había estudiado en Estados Unidos Ahí es
donde se convirtió en el mayor defensor
de occidente y el Libre Mercado sí mis
queridos amigos liberales y libertarios
que veis este canal si hay un héroe del
Estado mínimo y del liberalismo ese no
es otro que Michael sacasville
en 2003 libró lo que podríamos Llamar la
revolución liberal más exitosa de los
últimos 100 años la revolución de Las
Rosas vale hay que reconocer una cosa la
forma en la que llegó al poder no fue lo
más democrática del mundo pero seamos
claros recordad que Georgia era algo así
como la aldea de borat pero versión peor
en cualquier caso sacas Billy llegó al
poder con una promesa convertir a
Georgia en el paraíso del Libre Mercado
Eso significa lucha contra la corrupción
impuestos bajos y acuerdos de libre
comercio con todo el mundo para que os
hagáis una idea sus reformas fueron tan
radicales que incluso el fondo monetario
internacional dejó de prestar dinero al
país y diréis Pero por qué Pues porque
pensaban que con unos impuestos tan
bajos como querían poner serían
incapaces de devolver los préstamos sin
embargo adivináis qué es lo que pasó
pues atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
aquí lo tenéis Georgia tiene uno de los
sistemas Fiscales más minimalistas del
mundo recordáis nuestro vídeo de Estonia
pues Georgia tiene un modelo casi
idéntico al de Estonia a esto hay que
sumarle los acuerdos de libre comercio y
la limpieza del Estado para que os
hagáis una idea sacas Billy llegó a
despedir a más de 16.000 policías
corruptos en los primeros años de su
mandato Y sí ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos todo esto suena como el
sueño húmedo como la gran fantasía de
visualpolitik verdad Pues sí tenéis
razón por supuesto que a muchos os
parecerá un programa horrible de
gobierno pero lo cierto es que los datos
hablan por sí solos entre 2004 y 2007 el
pib de Georgia ejerció un 35% y la
inversión internacional se volcó en el
país
[Música]
por ponernos un ejemplo de inversión
extranjera fue en el año 2007 cuando
Ferrero que es la marca que fabrica la
nutella abrió una planta en el país para
poder procesar las avellanas Y es que sí
una de las principales exportaciones de
Georgia son los frutos secos eso y el
vino porque Georgia es conocida como el
lugar donde nació el vino Así que en
pocos años este país se dedicó a
exportar avellanas y vino como si no
hubiera mañana y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos Oye esto es sector
primario Dónde está la industria Dónde
están los servicios Pues sí tenéis razón
pero pensar que Georgia venía de ser la
aldea de borad Lo importante es que el
país Aunque seguía siendo pobre y
subdesarrollado estaba en la senda
correcta era la estrella del cáucaso Y
entonces es Cuando ocurrió la desgracia
atentos
las primeras Víctimas de Putin
otra de las promesas de sacasville al
llegar al poder fue la reunificación
nacional porque como os podéis imaginar
a los georgianos no les hacía nada de
Gracia tener a dos provincias que de
facto eran independientes y que
aparecían con sombreado de rayitas en el
mapa puede sonar un poco raro pero pese
a ser un país tan pequeño con menos de 4
millones de habitantes Georgia tiene
varios idiomas y etnias distintas y hay
dos regiones donde el georgiano no lo
quieren ver ni en pintura del sur y al
jaser
y que tienen en común estas regiones
pues aparte de no tener mucha simpatía
por Georgia tienen un enorme cariño por
la madre Rusia
Exacto esta historia os resulta familiar
es algo casi idéntico al Don vas o a
crimea pero no solo eso como ya os
podéis imaginar es difícil declarar tu
amor eterno por el Libre Mercado y por
occidente sin enfadarle un poquito a
Rusia Especialmente cuando sacas Billy
declaró su interés explícito por entrar
en la otan al igual que ha ocurrido con
Ucrania el primer ataque de Putin vino
por la cartera en el año 2006 Rusia
ordenó un boicot comercial contra
Georgia y diréis que vino después de la
cartera
Exacto el ataque militar Rusia chocan
por una región separatista en el año
2008 un grupo de separatistas diosetia
del sur pusieron una bomba a un grupo de
soldados georgianos Georgia había
intentado negociar una solución
territorial que permitiera que las
regiones Rebeldes aceptasen formar parte
de Georgia pero las negociaciones no
habían funcionado y este atentado fue la
gota que colmó el vaso primero el
ejército georgiano invadió o setia del
sur y después Rusia apoyo a los
obsequios del sur y así es como estalló
una guerra entre Rusia Georgia
al igual que la Guerra de Ucrania Rusia
también llegó hasta la capital de
Georgia de hecho Exactamente igual que
ha ocurrido en kiev los rusos también
bombardearon el aeropuerto de tiflis
pero no solo eso en solo 12 días Rusia
ocupó casi todo el país incluidas las
partes con población antirrusa sí Esto
es lo mismo que está pasando ahora mismo
en Ucrania pero con una diferencia los
georgianos estaban en una situación
mucho peor pensadlo bien el ejército de
Ucrania ha tenido casi 8 años para
prepararse para una invasión lo hemos
contado ya en muchos vídeos de
visualpolitik Sin embargo Georgia es un
país más pequeño con menos ejército y En
definitiva mucho más fácil de conquistar
invadir toda Ucrania llevaría mucho más
de 12 días en cualquier caso qué creéis
que pasa un Georgia
Pues en esta historia Francia con
Nicolás sarkozy me dio para negociar un
alto al fuego y Rusia consiguió lo que
quería el control de aurhasia y el
control de osetia del sur a cambio
retiraron las tropas del resto de
Georgia Cuál es la situación de Georgia
hoy en día pues atentos a este mapa en
los mapamundis de Rusia ausasia y osatio
del sur son dos repúblicas
independientes sin embargo ningún otro
país al menos ningún país que no sea un
parial lo reconoce como tal Así que en
los mapamundis del resto del mundo son
dos territorios de esos que están
sombreados con rayitas y afectos
prácticos estas dos repúblicas actúan
como dos provincias rusas incluso Usan
el rublo como moneda de curso legal En
otras palabras que parece muy razonable
pensar que tanto Doña esk como luhans
correrán la misma suerte y creedme no os
gustaría vivir en estas zonas La
pregunta es qué ha pasado en el resto de
Georgia han conseguido seguir con su
vida pese a la guerra con Rusia Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
entre Rusia y occidente
[Música]
en el año 2013 sacasville perdió las
elecciones Y quién diríais que le
sucedió Pues atentos porque esta es una
historia de personajes cuanto menos
pintorescos el sucesor de sacasville fue
este señor que veis en pantalla
hablamos de piscina y vannish Billy
También conocido con el apodo de Boris
este buen Señor hizo una auténtica
fortuna vendiendo ordenadores en Rusia
Durante los años 90 y diréis Pero como
de grande su fortuna Pues atentos porque
se calcula que este hombre tiene una
suma de dinero equivalente a la tercera
parte de todo el pib de Georgia sí
habéis oído bien y después de haber
hecho tantísimo dinero en Rusia volvió a
su Georgia natal para probar suerte en
la política Así que en 2012 creó su
propio partido al que llamó el sueño
georgiano y como os podéis imaginar con
tantísimo dinero para campaña electoral
el sueño georgiano arrasó en las
elecciones del año siguiente Pero no
solo eso tras ganar las elecciones sacas
Billy fue exiliado y perdió la
nacionalidad paréntesis sacas Billy es
uno de los pocos ejemplos de una persona
que ha llegado a ser técnicamente
apátrida es decir que durante un par de
años no tuvo ninguna nacionalidad pero
eso es historia para otro vídeo ya os he
dicho que sacas Billy daría para varias
series de Netflix
en cualquier caso desde el año 2013 el
partido de Billy ha dominado la política
georgiana y diréis Pero qué ideología
tiene este partido pues como os podéis
imaginar sueños georgiano es todo lo
propuso que puede llegar a ser un
partido en Georgia es decir No mucho
como os podéis imaginar la mayoría de
los georgianos no quieren ver a Rusia ni
en pintura no deja de ser el país con el
que todavía sigue en Guerra sin embargo
ivanis Billy es lo suficientemente
proruso como para lograr cosas como
estas Rusia lista para volver a importar
vino y agua georgiana pero no os
equivoquéis Georgia sigue muy lejos de
la Esfera de influencia rusa sí es
cierto desde el año 2013 Georgia ha
vuelto a conversar con Rusia pero no
creáis que son su único socio comercial
atentos la Unión Europea afirmó un
acuerdo de libre comercio con Georgia
Exacto Georgia comercial a la vez con
Rusia y con la Unión Europea todo esto
explica no solo El despegue de sus vinos
que cada vez se exportan más sino que
también explica la creación un nuevo
sector económico que hace décadas era
impensable en este país el turismo
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando turismo
pero pero Quién sería de vacaciones un
país que está en guerra pues atentos a
esta gráfica
[Música]
Lo cierto es que antes de la pandemia
Georgia llegó a tener casi 8 millones de
visitantes el crecimiento del turismo ha
sido casi milagroso sí es cierto que las
zonas ocupadas son peligrosas pero
ciudades como batumi se han llenado de
hoteles en primera línea de Costa muchos
de ellos financiados por capital
extranjero Georgia se ha convertido en
un destino relativamente barato para
turistas rusos y turistas turcos sin
embargo no es oro todo lo que reluce
sí es cierto la Georgia de hoy en día
está mucho mejor que la de hace 20 años
sin embargo el país todavía mantiene un
desempleo del 17%. en la última década
apenas han invertido en educación y como
resultado es difícil que surjan empresas
de alto valor añadido no hay mano de
obra bien formada eso por no hablar de
que el sistema es cada vez más
autoritario de hecho en el año 2021
metieron a sacasville en la cárcel por
razones bastante oscuras y Rusia sigue
presionando Para volver a incluir a
Georgia en su esfera de influencia Así
que es muy difícil pensar que este país
llegue algún día a ser miembro de la
Unión Europea o de la otan
[Música]
ahora bien hay una cosa indudable Hay
muchas muchas lecciones que se pueden
sacar de Georgia Así que la pregunta es
qué puede aprender Ucrania de Georgia es
posible que la parte oeste de Ucrania se
convierta en una economía modélica que
atraiga grandes cantidades de inversión
extranjera veremos un Boom del turismo
en kiev pueden otras industrias
innovadoras en Ucrania pese a estar en
guerra con Rusia podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]